vous savez que Kate et William Kate et
William dans France ce week-end regardez
petit récap après il y a Bertrand
Deckers
est-ce que ça t'intéresse toi qui a été
William tout ça Sophie ça te fait rire
bien sûr parce que moi je monte le cul
[Rires]
en France
c'est donc pour la Coupe du monde de
rugby qui démarre demain que le prince
et la princesse viennent dans l'Hexagone
et il faut dire que le rugby il semble
aimé ça puisque déjà en 2017 lors de
leur dernière visite officielle dans
notre pays ils étaient venus à Paris
pour échanger quelques ballons en plus
de se rendre à Marseille Kate et William
se dirigeront à Bordeaux alors que
vont-ils faire concrètement à quoi
ressemblera leur séjour en France
Bertrand Deckers nous donne le programme
de leur visite ce soir dans TPMP
[Applaudissements]
et Sophie elle aime tellement elle dit
William qu'elle veut aller regarder ça
chez elle non mais c'est vrai parce que
il y a les merci Sophie
et s par suff merci chérie merci alors
donc
à Kate et William ils viennent en France
à l'occasion de la coupe du monde de
rugby pour quel motif absolument quête
arrive samedi William dimanche
ils arrivent par les avions séparés ils
ne sont parfois des avions de ligne
pourquoi non non
nous avions privés ils prennent
dans l'avion quoi vos armes du roi
Charles III aux armes aux armes avec le
logo du roi Charles III d'Elisabeth II
on rappelle toute petite parenthèse
qu'il y a quasiment un an jour pour jour
qu'on perdait Elisabeth 2 8 7 ans ce
sera demain l'anniversaire de la mort
d'Elisabeth II il y aura demain déjà un
an non ils font pas grand chose
voilà donc pourquoi arriveront-ils de
façon sépare
pardon va à Marseille parce que
Marseille samedi ce sera le match de
l'Angleterre contre l'Argentine et ils
sont pas fort en plus là et on a fait
peur pour l'Angleterre c'est pas une
grosse équipe encore
mais elle a pris la présidence de la
fédération du rugby anglais qui
c'est pour ça qu'elle est samedi à
Marseille alors que William sera le
lendemain le dimanche lui à Bordeaux
puisque à Bordeaux
donc comme ils sont chacun ils ont un
patronage différent il se sépare les
jobs c'est ça la monarchie voilà on
travaille en famille de façon à être au
maximum présent sur les différents
terrains ils vont rester combien de
temps c'est de loustiques aller-retour
éclair Cyril on estime qu'ils arriveront
sur le coup des 19 heures le match
commence à 21h à Bordeaux vol privé on
sait déjà que la SDLP le service de la
protection qui a en charge la protection
des personnalités lorsqu'ils sont sur le
territoire français a été monopé
mobilisé en masse à Marseille et à
Bordeaux pour escorter le véhicule à
bord duquel ils vont prendre place on
estime que dans la soirée déjà il
repartiront sur le direct ensemble bah
non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant dans les sondages alors que
tu sais quand il a été couronné c'est
pas trop ça en critiquer un peu chargé
59 % on peut pas vraiment dire que c'est
le chiffre c'est pas vraiment c'est pas
Élisabeth Elisabeth
59% elle est équipée de fou Elisabeth II
elle culminait ça a été hors concours on
était à 90% de popularité Elisabeth II
et vous savez qui est la première
enquête de popularité chez les Windsor
c'est pas Jeannette
[Rires]
elle culmine aussi c'est la vraie
héritière d'Elizabeth et l'autre là
comment elle s'appelle Mégane alors
Mégane et ben ça c'est intéressant que
tu parles de médiane tu sais pourquoi
pourquoi est-ce que on trouve peut-être
que William était encore mouche
que moi en tout cas ce que l'on peut
dire pourquoi est-ce que William était
enfant peut-être un peu beaucoup se
déplacement il n'arrive pas ensemble il
ne repartent pas ensemble on sent que
tout est fait quand même pour que les
médias sont un peu excités on sentait
pas
il faut savoir qu'au même moment et bien
Harry il sera à Düsseldorf pour aller
vivre vous savez il a créé des jeux pour
[Rires]
pour des personnes handicapées
se dit que du côté de Kate et William et
bien il a il a un peu été tracté on a un
petit peu opéré la chose de façon à ce
que les caméras battent lorsqu'elles
sont à Marseille à Bordeaux vous m'avez
compris elles ne seront pas à du sel
d'or
petite des petites histoires de famille
alors donc il y a Charles III il va
venir dans 10 jours
mais parce que c'est la fameuse visite
diplomatique
on rappelle quand même que Emmanuel
Macron l'a invité donc il le Nord
l'invitation qu'il a reçu il avait été
annulé ça a été annulé parce que quand
il ramène sa fraise là
[Musique]
va s'étendre tu vas au 22 engagement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
évidemment il y aura le des membres du
gouvernement beaucoup des personnalités
on ne connaît pas encore vraiment la
liste officielle et surtout on attend
déjà sa risque de créer d'ailleurs une
petite polémique une sécurité incroyable
puisque Versailles est un peu un lieu
assez sécurisant par définition il
paraît d'ailleurs que pour quoi parce
que c'est immense le dernier grand dîner
on parle de la galerie des battes de la
galerie des glaces qui serait mobilisé
pour manger surtout pour agrandir et il
paraît que le le les hautes instances on
charge de la sécurité sont en train
d'étudier un système de drone Cyril qui
vont survoler le ciel Royal entre
guillemets si l'on peut dire de façon à
tenter de sécuriser ce site
ça sert à quoi là ce truc là
le dîner c'est pourquoi en fait ça pour
les relations absolument pour les
relations diplomatiques oui c'est c'est
on respecte le protocole en réalité
c'est la première fois qu'il pose le
clavier en territoire français depuis
qu'il est roi
les Anglais ont débarqué comment ben oui
les Anglais vont débarquer pour le sud
entre samedi dimanche et la semaine
prochaine c'est un mois en effet très
anglais très anglais tu es content oui
je suis content
l'année dernière si euh là William et
Kate il te croise et ce qu'ils savent
quitter ce qui
non vraiment t'as jamais fait de photos
avec eux non tu as déjà rencontré qui en
fait de je suis des je les suis en
déplacement et en voyage donc pour le
coup je les ai rencontrés je les vois
comme je te vois c'est très très
visiblement c'est très difficile eh tu
l'as vu comme tu me vois moi oui
j'ai des photos
j'ai eu la chance d'être en poste à
Londres au moment où il y avait le
mariage et le jubilé donc à ce moment-là
france télé c'était à fond sur les
déplacements donc je suis déplacé avec
elle plein de fois et je me suis pris
avec Charles aussi
[Applaudissements]
bravo tu vois plusieurs fois vraiment à
un mètre 50 tu pouvais lui parler enfin
après il y a les codes il faut pas
s'adresser il faut pas il faut l'appeler
la règle aussi
une fois ouais sur un déplacement
et Charles je te montrerai les photos je
suis avec lui sur un bateau je fais des
selfies les derrière toi directement
maintenant
[Rires]
tu as pris cette décision
c'est vrai c'est longuement réfléchi
d'accord bah bravo tu veux que je te
dise tu as pris la bonne décision et
bravo tu étais comme ça cet été j'étais
comme ça c'était oui bah oui
parce que là la mèche doit être collée
devant
[Applaudissements]